Fantastic work if you've got 12 n divided by 5. This 3 n minus 6 might have
given you trouble so let's see how to do it. We changed division to
multiplication, and multiplied by the reciprocal of our second fraction. Also
you might have noticed that I factored a 3 from the first two terms in the
numerator. I factored this and since I knew I was going to be multiplying my
numerators and my denominators together. I want to be able to find factors that
reduce to 1. You don't need to show all your simplification at once. So a lot of
times I think it's best to rewrite what's remaining. When we write out all the
factors, we can see that the 5s would reduce to 1 and one n would reduce to 1,
leaving us with 12 n divided by 5.